how do you recover from an unexpected
subscriber problem what happens to the
messages stay tuned to find out
[Music]
get out our asynchronous order
processing service is now looking to
deploy an updated subscriber code which
is great but the challenge is the new
executable may erroneously acknowledge
messages leading to message loss best
way to deal with this is well you
guessed it don't deploy the new code
well it's not ever an option that's
mostly not an option so what should they
really do well there is a feature in
cloud pub/sub called seek which extends
the subscriber functionality by allowing
you to change the acknowledgement state
of messages in bulk this means you can
replay previously acknowledged messages
there are two ways to perform seek
operations you can seek to a snapshot or
to a specific time if you seek to a
snapshot it allows you to capture the
message acknowledgement state of the
subscription this means once a snapshot
is created it retains all messages that
were unacknowledged in the source
subscription at the time of the
snapshots creation and any other
messages published to the topic after
that you can replay these unacknowledged
messages by using a snapshot to seek to
any of the topics subscriptions
snapshots expire and are deleted if the
oldest unacknowledged message in the
snapshot exceeds the message retention
duration so if your subscription was set
to retain messages for say 7 days but
you were a day behind in processing the
messages then the snapshot of the
subscription would expire after 6 days
you can use the same snapshot for
multiple subscriptions as long as they
have the same topic seeking to a time
marks every message received by pub/sub
before that time as acknowledged and all
the messages received after that time as
unacknowledged but to use the feature
you have to choose to retain
acknowledged messages on the
subscription this can be convenient but
usually costs more than snapshots it may
also be inaccurate due to possible clock
skews amongst the pubsub servers so if
you want to replay and reprocess
previously acknowledged messages just
seek to a prior time if ko'd is
deploying new code for a subscriber
there
should they seek to a snapshot or time
well they should seek to a snapshot
because incorporating snapshots into the
deployment process gives a way to
recover from bugs in the code if cannot
face an unexpected subscriber problem
and no relevant snapshot is available
then seeking to pass times is a good way
to recover with get out we saw two use
cases where you can use seek feature in
a new code deployment and in an
unexpected subscriber problem seek two
snapshots is also useful when testing
subscriber code for performance and
consistency because you have to use the
same data in every run snapshots enable
consistent data of its strong semantics
that was replaying messages what about
discarding what if cat out wants to just
save on processing time and cost on
backlogged messages that are no longer
relevant in situations like that you can
purge or discard those messages just
seek to a time in the future and all
those messages will be considered
acknowledged all right so today we learn
how to replay and purge messages in
cloud pub/sub using the seek feature by
seeking to a specific point in time or
to a snapshot if you want to try out to
seek feature yourself check out the
QuickStart linked in the description
below join us next time to learn more
about ordering messages in cloud pub/sub
until then give us a like subscribe and
let us know what else you want to learn
about cloud pub/sub
you
[Music]